ours changed a lot it's been about ten
years since this since I actually both
let me it's been about ten years since
we've had this arm meet up as I
mentioned earlier we start as a small
group and we've grown so I'm gonna take
a little bit of a retrospective between
our then and now I'm going to start with
the community and the community has
changed quite a lot in this time this
was the very first meetup we held on
April 2nd 2009 organized by Josh wreaths
and there's 21 people who RSVP'd
probably far fewer who showed up
this was our tenth anniversary Meetup
David Robinson live coded we sold out in
less than a week we are now space
constrained that's the only thing really
stopping us now is that we can't fit in
all the people because you can see that
graph there on the next slide we can see
we went from 21 members to almost 11,000
members as I mentioned earlier so that's
a very big group that's about a thousand
people a year it's really really grown
and the our community has changed the
face of it changed a little bit this was
us fitting in a small room for the one
that very first meetups there might be
some of you here actually right now and
you'll see that we fit in a small room
with lots of space between us well fast
forward to the conference which grew out
of that and there are many more of us in
there and because of the so we actually
get to take some pretty epic selfies
hey he's right there so we like to have
a lot of fun and the ecosystem for our
has changed quite a lot as well in the
past ten years the our packages ten
years ago we had about 2000 packages we
now have over 16,000 on cran so we have
a lot to thank cran for doing this it's
a lot of people putting their spare time
they put in a lot of effort for this the
way we used our has changed as well this
is what our used to look like it was
brutal
you entered code one line at a time and
hope you didn't mess up or you wrote it
in a text editor and you copy and paste
it thankfully we have our studio now and
it's so much easier we have a text
editor built in we have an environment
Spain we have files we have so much
going on and obviously we need the dark
background because no one a coffee shop
will know you're serious unless you have
a dark background and the prominent
members behind the tools have changed
ten years ago Brian Ripley was probably
the most prominent member and wrote most
of the code in our today
that's Hadley Wickham things have
changed quite a lot so let's take a look
at some old code and new code how was
like then and now because it was so much
harder back then
so is our first example we're going to
talk about calling multiple functions
it's a convoluted example something you
would never do this example but just to
get the point of calling one function to
the next in to the next so we will get
the fourth row of a data frame using
only the head and tail functions
immediately you're like no no don't do
it but it's just to show things so we
would write this call tail of head and
for head you say N equals four to get
the top four rows then of that you're
calling tail which we did earlier and
take the last row and that gets you the
fourth row you would never do this
outside a bash maybe well yeah and this
is maybe the way programmers write have
coded traditionally right you would go
inside and out and Excel jockey would
feel very comfortable here but
thankfully we have Meg Ritter however
you're supposed to pronounce that and
you use the pipes you say iris into head
and equals 4 into tail n equals 1 the
pipe has been so transformative it just
completely changes the way we work the
way we teach everything it's amazing
working directories dealing of paths
traditionally has been a bit of a pain
let's say you're in one folder for your
markdown document and you want to go
back to folders and then forward once
you get go dot dot slash dot dot slash
data and then if you're doing in one
working directory it gives you one thing
but if you're in a different working
directory it's a completely different
experience and then your homework
doesn't build and you're like oh my god
it can't submit this it's a pain and I'm
using it in conjunction of list dot
files to list all the files and it only
gives you the name of the files it's you
know not too friendly well now we have
the here package with the here function
and as long as you're in an our studio
project or some other scaffolding it
will create the absolute path to that
file or that directory for you all
dynamically so you can code it one way
in your laptop and hand it to someone
else and it works just fine on their
laptop or their server or any other
piece of equipment and it's really
really nice it's dynamic absolute paths
it's cross computer cross user it's very
portable and I combine that with the
Durrell Durrell s function from the FS
package to get the entire file name the
tire path not just the file name so
let's read in some data art could always
read in data will read in a CSV for
decades you would use read dot CSV you
can see here we're using the old syntax
for the path dot dot slash dot dot slash
data slash pizza places sample dot CSV
you read it in works just fine gives you
back a data frame ok you can't see all
the columns because it won't fit on my
screen it tries to print all the rows
because it doesn't know any better
and you don't know what types each of
the columns are in fact the text column
name is a factor it automatically got
converted to a factor I have spent hours
being bugged by this because no one
taught me strings as factors equals
false and if they did there's probably a
typo of all those s's so luckily we have
read our and read underscore CSV which a
I combined it with here to get the route
the absolute path dynamically it tells
you the column types and it has sensible
defaults so when you print it out it
only prints the first few rows
maybe the columns that fit and it tells
you the column types and it doesn't
convert strings to factors it's still a
character unless you want it to be a
factor which saves you a lot of
headaches so let's talk about sub
setting columns getting a subset of your
columns maybe the first time you used
our you try the sub set function you
would pass it a data frame then the
column names using non-standard
evaluation a decade ago and this can do
both columns and rows but there's a
catch if you ever read the help menu for
subsets you can get unanticipated
consequences
this is straight out of the help menu at
least they encourage you to use square
brackets so let's go ahead and use the
square brackets so if we see we take our
data frame pizza base square brackets
leave the first argument blank because
it's the rows give it the columns as
quoted names and it works works just
fine
guess what we wanted in fact if you're
using a Tibble which is New Zealand for
data frame you can do the same exact
thing it gives you back your data frame
or Tibble what happens if you only
supply one column name you get back a
vector no one taught me that and I spent
so much time taking my code if you have
two columns great you have one column
bad side to transpose it twice to get it
back to being the right orientation that
turned into a matrix ID to turn that
back into a data frame if someone just
told me about Drop equals false eh why
don't we know that and B why is the
default true so luckily with a Tibble
the default is false you just give it a
single column no matter how many columns
you give you will get back a data frame
either even if it's just one column if
you want to drop it you can do drop
equals true which makes a lot more sense
or you could use deep liar and select
your columns you pipe your data frame
into select and you give your column
names or no quotes so it's easier to use
interactively and yes if you give it
just one column name it gives you back a
data frame of one column as you would
hope for it and if for some reason you
wanted it to come back as a vector you
could use the pull function and let's
say you wanted to combine pipes and
square brackets you could by piping into
a square bracket and closed in backticks
and treating it like a function because
we can
so let's condition
we get rose based on some sort of
logical condition in base are you would
use square brackets and the first
argument you would put in the vector you
are doing the condition on and if it's
in the data frame you do data frame
dollar sign column in your condition
ugly and it also keeps all the row
numbers the old row numbers so 2 3 9 11
12 notice it's out of order with D prior
you pipe it into filter you give it your
condition just as a column name it's so
much cleaner so much easier to use this
is especially important if you have
multiple conditions like this case where
you say the price is greater than equal
to 3 and the city is New York we have
pizza base written three times you're
repeating yourself it's kind of messy so
using filter you list the data frame
once and then you give it the conditions
you can focus on the logic if you want
to get both rows and columns at the same
time of one command in base you would
use the first argument for rows the
second argument for columns all in one
command with deep liar each step is its
own thing
you first filter then you select it's
readable now let's see how plotting has
changed in the past ten years now ggplot
existed but it wasn't dominant people
used lattice or they used base this is
the Diamonds data set doing a scatter
plot first you have to specify the
colors you want manually then you use
the generic plot function with a formula
and yeah - then for to set your colors
subsets your vector using the column of
the data frame then you need to add your
own legend and remember where it goes
and how to do it I spent about two hours
making this graph
yeah and not that pretty
come along ggplot and look simple one
line of code I broke it up into two
lines make it readable it's easy to see
you give it your aesthetics and you can
tell you want points easy done totally
flexible another plot that was very
popular was a box plot this was great
when you had a pencil and paper but the
box represents the middle 50% which
means that thin line is 50% of your data
you're throwing away half of your data
with ggplot I can make Violin plots and
overlay the original data behind it
color coded by another variable so you
get a sense of the shape and density of
your plot for what is just technically
one long line of code and that gives you
so much more information than a box plot
ever will send a histogram
this is a basic histogram you need to
supply two vector with ggplot it's much
more attractive then you can use High
Charter to make it interactive this
slideshow is HTML you can move your
mouse over it when it's online you can
absolutely highlight things that have
this be an interactive plot with that
one little line of code time series
plotting got a lot better too this way
if you use the base plot on a time
series object on a multiple time series
object but if you use auto plot from the
forecast package you get a much nicer GG
plot all automatically done for you that
one-line much more attractive and there
are interactive packages like digraphs
which can help you also
let's aggregate some data do a group by
summary back in the day we would use
aggregate which is a great name for
aggregating but you give it a formula
and a data frame then the function which
is applied to the left-hand side of the
data frame and it's kind of slow
thankfully with deep liar it's more
sequel like you group by and you
summarize it's like sequel it's really
fast and it will work on a data frame or
a database or spark it's all the same
interface automatically
if you want to aggregate on multiple
outcome columns with base you need to
see buying the columns together even
though they're in a data frame I don't
know who came up with that but it's not
good UI with deep ire you only add it to
the summarized statement all you need to
do is specify more calculations so much
better modeling has changed a lot too so
much so that it became machine learning
and that changed a lot and became AI so
let's look at base our if you wanted to
fit a model you would first create a
formula and I saved it to a variable for
later use and in this case I'm taking a
log of the outcome variable I'm scaling
caret XY and Z and I'm including my cut
variable as a dummy as a categorical
this is incredibly powerful at one our
statistical computing award but it's
been over matched by wide data and it
only really helps you of your training
data it doesn't help you if your new
data thankfully there's a great new
package called recipes which lets you
programmatically go step by step yes it
looks like more code but it's more
programmatic you give it a simple
formula with no transformations you
Center and scale your numeric variables
you turn your categorical into dummy's
you add an intercept you take a log of
your outcome and then when you prep it
it does the calculations it does the
computations when you're ready to use
that on either your training or your
test data
you either juice or bake yes there's a
real function names but it really helps
you a lot it works on both the training
data and the test data let's go ahead
and fit a model a linear model base are
you call LM it's tested it's easy and
it's actually very fast it works really
well but it just fits L M if you want a
little bit of nostalgia there's a new
parsnip package based on a derivative of
carrot and first you tell you're doing
linear regression then you set the
engine you tell your doing LM and then
you fit it based on the training date of
a simple little formula at the end there
and this might seem like more code than
calling LM but let's say you don't want
to use LM you want to use Stan you
simply change the engine to stand if you
want to use spark because your data is
already in a grid you change it to spark
if you want penalize regression you
change it to glue net if you want to fit
a linear neural network you change it to
Kharis notice that it's all the same
thing you
changing one line of code one string and
one line of code how easy is that it's
really amazing this package and speaking
of neural nets they've been in our for
decades
Brian Ripley and Bill Venables wrote the
N net function decades ago just like LM
it takes a formula and a data frame and
you tell it how many nodes are in your
hidden layer and it fits a neural
network it's only a one layer neural
network so if you want to get a little
more advanced you use care us it's a lot
more code but it lets you capture more
complex relationships you in this case
it stole a single layer it's a dense
layer 64 units in an outcome you have to
compile in place which is not very our
like but it works
you tell it how you're gonna optimize
your loss function and they actually fit
the model the way we get help change a
lot too you used to go to the our help
list or you might be greeted by things
like once you appreciate you have
seriously misread the page things become
a lot easier clearer give let you guess
who that is and someone even responded
to this with hopefully this isn't in the
manual I'm about to get shot it wasn't
nice but thankfully we have people like
Maura answering questions on Twitter and
a great welcome friendly manner and
people like attending this conference
who are very welcoming and open to
helping people out so a lot has happened
in 10 years that since we've had the our
meetup and I'm thinking more towards my
personal future as I have welcomed a new
our programmer
[Music]
and those matching shirts were given to
us by the länder analytics team and
designed by Vivian pang who will be here
tomorrow because they're not just hex
tickers they're baby themed hex tickers
yeah I love tiny verse messy arbor bar
it was a lot of fun seen that sure is
one of the greatest kiss I ever got so
thank you very much
you